Hi everyone. In
this lecture, I will
talk about CNS
infections, and I will
discuss specifically
the treatments for
bacterial, viral, and
fungal meningitis.
I will say that most
of this lecture,
especially with respect
to the antimicrobials,
should be a
review for you. So
I have chosen to
review the mechanisms,
the adverse effects,
and drug interactions
that are specific
to the drugs that
we use to treat
bacterial meningitis.
I will also discuss
the mechanisms of
antivirals and
antifungals that can treat
those two specific
types of meningitis.
And then I will
talk about the role
of glucocorticoids.
and this group is
mainly used for
supportive treatment.
Some studies have
said that using a
glucocorticoid with
bacterial meningitis does
reduce some of the
swelling and also
there may be some
residual hearing loss that
may be prevented
with glucocorticoids.
with viral
glucocorticoids can
also attain the
same thing with
respect to reducing
some of the
edema in in the brain
but some studies
can also say that
maybe glucocorticoids
are not necessary so
anyway i will just
go through again and
review their mechanism
and their specific
adverse effects
so i am not going to
test you on specific
bugs and drugs the exam
and probably even step
one of the boards is
really going to ask
about mechanism and
adverse effects but i have
highlighted the three
major microorganisms
that are implicated in
bacterial meningitis
and you can see
for strep and
nisteria the
standard therapy is
going to be a
third generation
cephalosporin and
there's a couple of
reasons for that and
I will embellish as we
get into the lecture
and then with strep
you also want to have
coverage for MRSA
and that's why you
would give vancomycin.
Listeria is going
to be treated with
a beta-lactam plus
an aminoglycoside.
And H-flu is
also going to get
a third-generation
cephalosporin.
So I'll say it
very briefly.
Third-generation
cephalosporins are good
for empiric coverage
because, number one,
third regeneration
has the ability
to cover both gram
-positive and gram-negative
bacteria. So before
you even get the
results of the culture,
you need to start
empiric therapy for
meningitis because
if you don't, that's
going to be very
dangerous for the patient.
The next thing is that
cephalosporins are
also considered to
be bactericidal. For
these type of
infections, you want
something that's going
to kill the bacteria
outright you don't
want to when you know
the word is you
don't want to rely
on the host the
patient's immune function
you want something
that's going
to kill the
bacteria because as
mentioned this infection
is very serious
and the other thing
about third generation
which is very important
it's able to cross
the blood brain barrier.
They're considered
to be lipophilic. So
this is why in the
empiric treatment for
meningitis, most of
the time you're going
to see ceftriaxone,
ceftazidine, and those
are third generation.
If there's an issue,
there are alternatives.
You can see
fluoroquinolones
can be on that list,
meropenem, maybe
chloramphenicol. So I'll
go through these
mechanisms in the lecture.
For group B strep
in babies, which is
attributed to strep
aglacticae and E. coli
in neonates, you would
also use beta-lactams.
Because again,
when we're talking
about specific
populations, when it's a
pregnant patient or it's
a pediatric patient,
beta-lactams are
considered to be safe.
And then the
other thing which
applies mainly
to Nasseria is
the importance
of vaccination.
So I'm not going to
give you the exact
timing, but I know that
the first shot should
be about the age of 11,
because I think there
has to be another shot
in later adolescence,
especially, and I
think many of you have
gone through this, if
you're talking about
going to college
and living in a dorm
this is very important
okay so where we can
vaccinate we should
be vaccinating i'm not
gonna test you on what
to look for in the
cerebral spinal fluid but
you should be familiar
when you read questions
so for example
bacterial meningitis
is going to have a low
glucose because that
seems to be attributed
that the cells are
taking up the glucose
that's why the glucose
would be low and the
other thing is that
the the liquid itself
would be more cloudy
okay with respect to
viral and fungal
meningitis what was going
to be the difference
is that with viral
meningitis, the protein
is low. With fungal
is high, just like in
bacterial meningitis.
But the glucose for
both of those are
normal or normal to low.
So here we go with
antimicrobials. And
I'm not going to focus
too much on introductory
principles because
you've had this
already, but it's a
good idea to review.
Bacteriostatic is
where you start the
medication and there's
going to be a plateau
where you're
inhibiting the growth
of the bacteria. But
as you can see here,
you're going to rely
on the patient's
defense mechanisms
to eradicate the
bacteria. So that's
going to be true with
many of the protein
synthesis inhibitors
except aminoglycosides,
tetracyclines,
okay?
Bacteriocidal, and I
have that highlighted,
as you can see here
in the picture.
You see when you
start the medication,
the log cell number
is going to go down
abruptly because you
are aiming to kill the
bacteria. And that's
what you want in a
serious infection
like this. Because
meningitis, the effects
can be long-lasting.
thing. There are some
patients who spend many
months and years
recovering if they do.
Patients can
actually die from
meningitis. So that's
why getting something
that is bactericidal
is important.
And then we want
broad spectrum. We
cannot wait for the
culture to come back.
We have to start
something right
away. And that is why
a third generation
cephalosporin is
so valuable. Okay.
And the other thing
to note, and I
mentioned, is that
the third generations,
they're lipophilic.
They cross the blood
-brain barrier, so
you don't have to
worry about anything
pharmacokinetically.
And then remember,
narrow spectrum is going
to cover only gram
-positive. So I guess
the best example
would be if you had a
treponema or ********,
it would be penicillin
G, and that's a narrow
spectrum antibiotic.
Very briefly with
the cell wall.
Gram positive, as you
can see on the left,
is considered to have
a thick cell wall.
There's lots of
peptidoglycans
in there, as you can see.
And as you can
also visualize,
the stain is going
to be purple.
And with the
peptidoglycan, we also
would expect a
large amount of beta
-lactamase to be
secreted, and that
can be a mechanism
of resistance.
With respect to gram
-negative, as you
can see, the cell
wall is a lot thinner.
There is a
larger or greater
amount of lipids present.
When you stain this
thinner cell wall,
it's going to appear
to be pink. And then
you're going to
have the presence of
porins. And porins
are going to be
interesting because
later when I talk about
resistance, with
gram-negative, there
may be an alteration
in those channels.
So cell wall
inhibitors, all of them
are bactericidal.
And that's going to
be true penicillins,
cephalosporins,
carbapenems.
And as you can see,
the penicillins,
the earlier ones are
going to treat mostly
gram-positive. And
that's true. I talked
about penicillin G
intramuscularly for
******** or treponema.
Syphilospirants
also follow the
same thing. The
older ones are more
broad spectrum
for gram-positive
as you go into
later generations,
third, fourth, and
fifth. you're going
to see that the
coverage now becomes
more broad. It can
cover positive and
negative bacteria.
And that's going to
be true if we're
talking about something
like Neisseria or
maybe H-influenza.
Monobactams,
astrionam, is a
specific drug for
gram-negative.
And carbapenins are
also broad spectrum.
There's a couple of them
that we will cover. I
believe meropenem
is the one that they
oftentimes use for certain
cases of meningitis.
Not empiric though.
And then the non-beta
-lactams, they'll still
affect cell wall
synthesis, but they don't
bind to transpeptidase,
as you can see
here, are going to be
vanco and daptomycin.
so the beta lactams
the name comes from the
fact that they share
this ring okay this
square with a nitrogen
and an oxygen group
okay beta lactamase
will disrupt this ring
and it's a major method
for drug resistance
so we have beta
-lactamase inhibitors and
you should know maybe
familiar with one of
them we have amoxicillin
and then we have
augmentin amoxicillin
and clavulanic acid
clavulanic acid is not
doing anything to kill
the bacteria the
amoxicillin is but that
drug is stopping beta
-lactamase from degrading
this beta-lactam ring
okay and the same
thing is is true for
i believe silbactam
and tazobactam and
those are mainly given
with some of the more
injectable penicillins
okay so as i said beta
-lactamase you could
use a suicide inhibitor
and that's again
another name for
clavulanic acid for
silbactam tazobactam
there's a couple of
more that have been
brought to the market
Another method of
resistance is going
to be mutation of the
penicillin binding
proteins. And that's
going to be true
of the MRSA infections.
So dicloxacillin
will have this
resistance mechanism.
If you're mutating
those binding proteins,
the drug cannot
bind and do the job.
Pour in
downregulation, and I
mentioned that in
that first slide.
Those channels,
if they're down
-regulated, they
may not be able
to get the drug
inside the cell.
And then there may
be the production
of something called
efflux channels. And
efflux just does
that. The drug is
pumped in, but these
channels allow the
drug to pump out. And
I believe tetracyclines
have that resistance
mechanism.
okay i am not
going to test you
on specific uses
by the time you
become a physician
you'll be more
um fluent so to speak
in that and the other
thing is something that
i have to always um
say you know things
change resistances happen
okay so when i was
doing rotations in the
hospital vancomycin
was everywhere for MRSA
and it still is but
then there started to
become resistance to
vancomycin and now we have
new drugs like linezolid
or daptomycin or
septaroline which is
a fifth generation
cephalosporin so I am
not really a proponent
of memorizing bug to
drug because it could
change so I am a proponent
of you understanding
the mechanism, the
adverse effects,
the drug interactions,
and of course, to
make sure you stay up
on the knowledge here.
Piperacillin, Ticlocilin,
and Carbenicillin
are really used for
pseudomonas, and I
need to mention that
because pseudomonas in
the past is gram
-negative, it's aerobic and
it's a rod, they
used to use a lot of
aminoglycosides, but
aminoglycosides come with
a whole host of
toxicities, which I'll
explain in a moment.
so now we have these
medications and these
ones here the anti
-pseudomonosal ones also
come with the beta-lactam
inhibitor like sulbactam
and tazobactam.
Amoxicillin that's the
amino penicillin this
is very good both of
them ampicillin and
amoxicillin both have
the the nitrogen group
this is where we
started to see more of a
broad spectrum with
these okay so you can see
penicillin g
dicloxacillin specific for
gram positive bacteria
now you got to see that
amoxicillin can treat
h pylori and that is
a gram negative
bacteria that happens in
the gi tract that could
cause *** same thing
with h influenza it's
gram negative if you
have otitis media you
can give amoxicillin.
So the one thing about
penicillins is that
the adverse effects
are pretty minimum.
There may be some GI
upset which can lead in
worst case scenario
to pseudomembranous
colitis but really
with penicillin what we
have to consider is
the anaphylaxis, which
is rare, but with
anaphylaxis, you will end
up having some problems
with your airway.
The other thing is the
allergy to penicillin
can be cross
-reactive with
cephalosporins, another
beta-lactam inhibitor.
It used to be 10%.
They would say
there's a 10%
cross-reactivity.
In years, recent
years, they've
actually put it down.
They say it's 1% to
2%. And it really
has to do with
those patients that
are getting older,
cephalosporins, and
those drugs that
have a similar side
chain in the structure.
That's where the
allergies are more
prominent. it. The
other thing to know
is that you need to
distinguish between
what's an allergy and
an adverse effect.
Because oftentimes
patients in the
pharmacy, we have
to ask them at every
encounter, do you
have any allergies
to medication?
And you might get
the person that
says penicillin.
It's always good to
ask what that meant.
Because sometimes
patients would say, well,
you know, I took
penicillin and I had
really bad diarrhea
and my stomach was
bothering me for like
three days that's not
an allergy that's an
adverse effect so we
need to be very clear
with the patient
what's an allergy
what's an adverse effect
obviously if it's
an allergy it has to
be documented and it
has to be everybody
has to know whether
it's you as a physician
whether it's your
friend who's another
type of physician the
pharmacy the nurse
that's something that's
really important.
Probenicid decreases
excretion and this
has to do with the
fact that probenicid
is a drug that we
use for gout or
hyperuricemia. When
you give probenicid,
what happens is
that you end up
preventing the
reabsorption of uric acid.
So that person
excretes uric acid and
they're not going to
have a gouty attack.
Probenicid, when it
comes to penicillins,
it actually allows
for recovery. So you
decrease excretion.
So in earlier times
when we had a shortage
of penicillins,
which hopefully is never
the case, they would
sometimes give
probenicid to make the
penicillin more long
-acting, so to speak.
Interstitial
nephritis can happen.
This is where now
it's almost like an
allergic reaction
where the drug in the
kidney behaves like
a haptin. So the
patient may have
some increase in
asinophils. They may
have some rashes.
Again, very rare.
So again, what shares a
penicillin
hypersensitivity?
The penicillin,
cephalosporins,
carbapenins. And as
I said, it's going
to be more directed
towards those
drugs that have
similar side chains.
Estrionam and vancomycin
are not, they don't
have beta-lactam in
the structure. So,
estrionam would be safe
if you had a gram-negative
organism and you
needed a penicillin and
that patient had a true
penicillin allergy.
Vanco works a little
bit differently
and we'll talk about
it in a moment.
So the carbapenems
I have in
that first chart
as an alternate
drug, miropenem
could be used.
These newer ones do
not need psilastatin
because you probably
have seen the formulation
called imipenem and
psilastatin. And
psilastatin is not a
drug for hyperlipidemia.
It's just the way
it's named. these two
imipenem and psilastatin
were put together
because psilastatin
prevents the breakdown
of this antibiotic in
the kidney it inhibits
an enzyme known as
dehydropeptidase and
by doing that not only
are you keeping the
drug a little bit long
acting but you are
discouraging,
so to speak, the
formation of a
nephrotoxic metabolite.
And that nephrotoxic
metabolite can
sometimes increase
CNS disturbances.
Etripenem is the longest
acting. It has the
longest half-life, but
it's very irritating.
So when you give this
medication, you have
to give something like
lidocaine. So remember,
but lidocaine is a
local anesthetic, and
that would be appropriate.
It's an amide.
These drugs are
really good for gram
-negative aerobic
bacteria, more so
than the gram
-positive. So a lot of
these urinary tract
infections that
happen respond very
well to this group.
The only issue
is, because when I
think of UTIs, I
think of elderly
patients, these are
renally eliminated.
So if you have a
reduction in renal
function, you're
going to get, as I
mentioned, an increase
in metabolites,
and that can raise
the seizure risk.
Cephalosporins,
they're going
to inhibit
transpeptidase.
The earlier
generations have a very
poor distribution
in the CNS, but
generation 3, 4, and
5 are lipophilic.
The adverse effects
is again similar to
penicillins. You may
have pseudomembranous
colitis. You may have
interstitial nephritis,
and there's a small
possibility of hypersensitivity
if you are allergic
to penicillin.
The other thing to
know is that there
are a couple of
drugs. We have
cefropirazone, which
is generation 2, and
cefamandol, which
is generation 3.
They have something
in their structure
known as a methyl
thioterazole ring.
And this particular
part of the ring has an
inhibition of vitamin
K epoxide reductase.
And you don't know much
about this yet. this
is a mechanism for
something like warfarin,
which is an anticoagulant.
So oftentimes if
patients are taking
anticoagulants, they can
get more of a bleed
with those two. I will
say they're not as
commonly used anymore
because we have other
drugs that can be used.
And the other thing
is that those two
can cause a disulfiram
-like reaction. So
similar what you saw
with antabuse when
we were doing alcohol
use disorder, or
the other one would
be metronidazole.
So with a disulfiram
reaction, what
happens is if you
consume alcohol,
you inhibit the
acetylaldehyde dehydrogenase,
and you recover
acetylaldehyde,
and that's going to
cause the redness,
the flushing, and
the tachycardia.
So that's just a
little bit of a review.
so i didn't put
fifth generation
is ceftaroline
that's also given
intravenously
ceftaroline is actually
the one with even
more resistance to
to beta-lactamase
than the previous
generations and ceftaroline
by the way is used
for MRSA infections
but the one that
is used the most is
a third generation.
Because number one,
as I mentioned,
they're bacteriocidal.
They cross the blood
-brain barrier, okay?
And they are broad
spectrum. So they
can treat the positive
strep pneumonia,
and they can treat
the gram-negative
H influenza
meningitis infections.
so vanco as i said
will be used for mercer
this is another cell
wall synthesis inhibitor
but it's for gram
positive bacteria like
mercer it's used ******
for c difficile so
this is another place
where things have changed
when patients had c
difficile in the past
they would use
metronidazole. That's what
I learned. And you
only gave vancomycin if
the patient had more
of a serious infection.
Over time, they
started saying that,
no, we can give
metro, but we're going
to make vanco first
line. So that's
why I said with
these protocols for
antibiotics, they
are prone to change.
Vanco is not going to
affect transpeptidase.
It's going to bind
to the D-alanine
subunit okay a couple
of things that you
have to be mindful
is that this drug can
cause ototoxicity
and nephrotoxicity so
if you ever had to
give vancomycin with
something that's
also sharing the same
toxicities like
aminoglycosides you have to
be very careful or
maybe not give it all
same thing if you were
giving say cisplatin
and you don't know
about cisplatin yet but
it's a cancer drug
and it has the same
side effect profile as
aminoglycosides. You
need to be very mindful
of the patient's BUN
and creatinine and
monitor their hearing.
The other thing is this
red man syndrome and
this was interesting
because I was teaching
this for a while and
you know students
would hear me say it
a lot and you know
students just memorize
for the exam and and you
and you forget but I
did get an email from
a student and they
said that they saw red
man's on their rotation
and the reason was
because they did not
infuse it slowly like
I have here in in the
slide if you infuse
this too fast what
happens is you're going to
get a release of histamine
and the histamine
is going to cause the
patient to be flushed
in their face their
neck their trunk it's
not something that
is dangerous but it
will be something your
patient is not going
to appreciate so what
i would recommend you
infuse it slowly and you
give them a histamine
blocker like
diphenhydramine a small
dose and then vanco
started to have their
resistance problems as
I have mentioned. And
that's because the D
-alanine was replaced by
D-lactate. So now you
have to use another
medication. There's
Lineslid, there's
Daptomycin, there's
Ceftaroline,
there's Quinipristin
and Dalfopristin.
There's a couple of
options. So you should
have some coverage.
Here it's, this is
very important because
this is a really
good slide because it
shows you everything
from the beginning.
There is a drug that
they use for TB that's
known as cycloserine
and that's going to
block the conversion
of alanine to dealanine
because it blocks
alanine racemase.
It's not used predominantly
in patients that
have TB because it has
nephrotoxic effects
actually more
neurotoxic effects I'm
sorry but it is used
in in some cases where
the patient has multi
-drug resistant TB.
So this is not
part of what we we
care about right
now with meningitis.
When you get
D-alanine then
there's going to
be a conversion
of the D-alanine
to 2-D-alanine
and that is where
vancomycin will bind.
So you can envision
that with the
resistance the D
-alanine becomes lactate.
But then continuing
on, you're also
going to get from
L-alanine, and
you're going to add
on glycopeptides,
you're going to
ultimately want to make
the rigid
peptidoglycan cell wall
with the crosslinks.
That's going
to give the cell
wall rigidity.
And what you need
to obtain that is
transpeptidase. And
that is where all of the
beta-lactams will bind,
whether it's penicillin,
amoxicillin,
ceftriaxone, estreonam.
They're going to
inhibit transpeptidase.
speaking of tuberculosis
the drug therapy for
tuberculosis is going
to be six months of
ripe therapy okay ripe
stands for rifampin
isoniazid pyrazinamide
and ethambutol okay for
the first couple of
months it's four drugs
and then after the two
months there's four
more months, because
it's a six-month total,
of rifampin or isoniazid.
So why do we care
about this right now?
There's going to be
a certain situation
where if you are
exposed to meningitis
in, say, a group,
whether you're in a dorm
or you're in the army
or in jails, that if
you're exposed, they're
going to make sure
you go to the
hospital and you start
therapy right away. But
there's going to be a
concern for the people
that you live with.
Rifampin has been shown
to be one of these
drugs that can be a
prophylactic measure
for meningitis in
those people that may
have been exposed. And
rifampin, I call it
the R drug because it
inhibits DNA dependent
RNA polymerase. So
it's going to stop
the synthesis, as you
can see here, of RNA.
The adverse effects is
number one, and I'll
give this to first
aid because they do it
well. It revs up
metabolism. So that means
it's an inducer of
SIP. So now if you're
living in the dorm and
you're taking rifampin
and you are a student
who is trying to
prevent pregnancy with
an oral contraceptive,
the oral contraceptive's
metabolism can
be induced and then
you're going to get
failure of your oral
contraceptive so in
that case you need to
tell the patient to
use another method of
birth control because
of the induction
the other thing is
that it does have some
liver toxicity and
this is especially
going to be true when
it's combined with
pyrazinamide and
ethembutol and isoniazid
and that's for next
year but it the drug
if you ever look it
up the the way it's
synthesized it's red
so one thing to know
is that sometimes
patients will say
that when they use the
bathroom when they
urinate when they take
their contact out in
their saliva they'll
see red now this is
actually not a bad
thing because it's
actually a way for us
to know that patients
are being compliant
especially if we're
talking about
treating TB.
But the thing to
understand is to let them
know that this is a
benign side effect.
And now the resistance
has to do with
the fact that there
is an alteration
in DNA-dependent
RNA polymerase.
So next are the NATs.
and those are
aminoglycosides again
this is another
first aid mnemonic
where Nats is
Gent, Neomycin,
Amicacin, Tobramycin
and Streptomycin
aminoglycosides are
protein synthesis
inhibitors but they
are bactericidal
so drug binds to
30S it makes a
covalent bond and
you get a shutdown of
protein synthesis
And that shuts down
the 30S ribosomes
that are available.
The other thing is
on the messenger
RNA, there's going
to be a misreading
of the code. So if that's
happening, then you
cannot continue on.
Okay, that's the
beginning step.
So that's going
to produce
a defective protein.
So the thing to know
is that they're going
to stop initiation
of protein synthesis.
their resistance can
be a mutation in the
ribosome there can be
a decreased uptake of
the drug because they
are used mainly for
gram negative and we
talked about porins and
there's enzymes that
can inactivate the
drug acetyl, adenyl,
and phosphatransferases
so now we're
talking about
the noro, oto, and
nephrotoxicity So,
neuro, you're
going to decrease
acetylcholine, and
if you are decreasing
that, thinking
about the whole idea
of muscle, you can't
contract muscle.
So, anybody
with myasthenia,
Parkinsonism, and
those that just
had a neuromuscular
blocker like
pancoronium as part
of their anesthesia
might be more prone
to these muscle
effects. So they
should be avoided.
Ototoxicity, free
radicals will deposit in
the inner ear and they
can also affect the
vestibular apparatus
which is for balance.
And that can cause an
irreversible effect.
So ototoxicity is
important. And when
you're taking other
medications, and I
mentioned cisplatin
being the cancer
drug or a loop
diuretic, which you'll
talk about next fall
when we do cardio,
loop diuretics
are ototoxic.
If you ever gave a
loop diuretic for
somebody with CHF
and they needed an
aminoglycoside, they
can tell you that
they are experiencing
trouble hearing.
And then in pregnancy,
cranial nerve aid damage
can occur, and that
child can be born with
difficulty hearing.
And then is the
nephrotoxicity,
which incidentally
is reversible.
The drug will concentrate
in the proximal
tubule, and there's
going to be formation of
ROSs in the mitochondria,
so you're getting
a change in energy. and
what happens is that
even in the organelles,
the lysosomes there
may be some spillage
out of some of that
debris that can cause
trouble with the kidney
ultimately acute
tubular necrosis happens
where the patient
cannot concentrate
their urine and they
end up in non-oliguric
renal failure where
incidentally this
is not so bad which
is why this is
reversible, this is
where the patient has
really no effects on
urine output. And that's
usually one of the
better places to
be if you're talking
about renal injury.
But the thing
you have to know,
if you gave
aminoglycosides with
another nephrotoxic
drug, which I
will talk about
in a few minutes,
Amphotericin, which
is used for fungal
meningitis, you can get
more nephrotoxicity.
The other thing about
aminoglycosides,
and this is an
important point,
is that it has that
post-antibiotic effect.
So that, remember,
means that the drug
still keeps working
even when removed
and the drug
concentration goes below
the minimum inhibitory
concentration.
and that's good because
that would allow you now
to dose this
once a day or
even once every other day
because you take
the drug off and
the action still
persists the
killing of the
bacteria persists and
that's special to
aminoglycosides
corinfenacol is broad
spectrum it's
bacteriostatic
and so again, we
said initially
we want something
bactericidal.
Once you get the culture,
this may be then
the drug you might
use depending on how
that result comes.
The other thing is that
chloramphenicol is
very lipophilic so
that makes it
another good thing.
This will inhibit
peptide formation by
binding to peptidyl
transferase on the
50S. So chloramphenicol,
clindamycin,
macrolides, or 50S.
Since it's lipophilic,
it's used for a
lot of types of
bacteria that involve
the brain. for brain
abscess, for the
meningitis, for typhoid,
and for something
called Rocky Mountain
Spotted Fever,
which is a
rickettsia infection
that is, you get
it from animals.
So if you are out
hiking in certain areas
of the world or country,
this could happen.
And normally
doxycycline is first,
but chloramphenicol
could be used
because it's
extremely lipophilic.
It's eliminated by
glucuronidation, and
that's an important point
coming up. It's widely
distributed into
fluids, so CSF, great.
You may want to
reduce the dose in
liver failure
because it does go
through phase 2
glucuronidation.
So adverse effects.
number one it's a protein
synthesis inhibitor
and in the
mitochondria of
certain blood cells
that can reduce well
specifically it's
going to be in
the bone marrow if
you're getting protein
synthesis inhibition
in the bone marrow
you're going
to get a reduction
in your blood cells
and that can be the
reason why patients get
bone marrow suppression
for the aplastic
anemia it may be a rare
idiosyncratic reaction.
So if the patient
presents with fatigue,
bruising, fever,
sore throat, you
need to do a CBC and
check things out.
And then next is the
gray baby syndrome.
And this goes back to
the glucuronidation.
If this needs to
be glucuronidated,
you need something
called UDP cofactor.
UDP cofactor is not
there when you're born.
So if this was given
in pregnancy or in
early life, the baby
cannot metabolize it.
So the drug now
kind of stays
around and it
causes cyanosis,
hypotension,
and the cyanosis
will appear
that the baby looks gray.
That's where we
get gray baby.
And the resistance
is that bacteria
are impermeable
to the drug
and the drug may
be acetylated.
So tetracyclines
are going to be
protein synthesis
inhibitors because
I talked about
the rickettsia.
And the thing to
know is that they're
going to stop elongation.
So on messenger
RNA, tetracyclines
will be here and bind.
And that means now
that transfer RNA
can't come in and
make this peptide
longer. It can't
like string on
more aminoglycosides.
So that's where
stopping elongation
is important.
The important
things here is going
to be the rickettsial
meningitis.
Doxycycline is
first line, as
it is for Borrelia
infections.
And Borrelia is
the very simple
way of saying
Lyme's disease.
Dimeclacycline
treats syndrome of
inappropriate antidiuretic
hormone. This is
where now, and I
mentioned it, I believe it
was with carbamazepine.
That's going to
have now the patient
retain more water
and the patient will
become hyponatremic.
So, demiclocycline
actually will
inhibit ADH.
And what it does is it
will correct the low
sodium by making your
urine more dilute. So
it's almost acting like
what lithium and then
with lithium, remember
with this mechanism,
that's where you get the
polyureum polydipsia.
So that's how you
would correct SIADH.
And then these drugs
are renally eliminated.
Doxy is fecally
eliminated and that's an
important point. And as
mentioned, tetracyclines
like fluoroquinolones,
they can
distribute into the
bones, and that can be a
problem with growth,
especially in peds.
It can deposit
in breast milk.
And then the other place,
again, if it always
finds the divalence
or trivalent cation,
is going to be the
teeth. And that's why
if you give this
medication class in peds
or pregnancy, the baby
will have this teeth
staining, which really
cannot be reversed.
Okay, so avoid
tetracyclines
in peds and in pregnancy.
Some other things,
the photosensitivity
is important. We know
that. Use sunscreen.
um azotemia may be
due to the fact that
if you are affecting
protein synthesis
there may be more
protein perhaps in the
blood and that can
be more uh forming
nitrogenous waste because
that's what azotema
is okay outdated
tetracyclines can affect
the proximal tubule
and that will cause
Fanconi syndrome.
So you get rid of
your sugar, you get
rid of your glucose,
you get rid of
some of the idea
with calcium.
Vertigo can
happen. And of
course, this
one has a strong
propensity to
cause C. difficile.
So again, if the patient
complains of many
bouts of diarrhea
with antibiotics, the
one with the most is
clindamycin, by the
way. You need to make
sure that they get
evaluated because you
may have to stop the
medication. Because
if it becomes C.
diff, you can get
pseudomembranous colitis.
And then as I mentioned
with tetracyclines,
there may be some
issue with the efflux
pumps being upregulated
and that's going
to allow now more
drug to be pumped out.
So the next
group is going
to be the
fluoroquinolones.
Just as the name
says, these have
a fluorine in
their structure.
We recognize them that at
the end it's phloxacin.
The use for earlier
generation was
that it was more broad
spectrum, meaning
that it would
treat the gram
-negative rods, like
those that are present
in the urinary
and the GI tract.
Some of the newer ones,
like levofloxacin,
moxifloxacin, can be
used to treat more gram
-positive infections,
like strep pneumonia.
So I like to say that
with ciprofloxacin,
when it was first
developed, it seemed
like it was more
broad spectrum, and
now it's gotten more
narrow, depending
on the drug. These
are bactericidal,
and they're going
to block an enzyme
known as DNA gyrase
and topoosomerase 4.
And these are involved
in replication.
So let's make this a
little bit clearer.
When you want to make
another DNA, you need
to get two separated
strands, because
one strand becomes a
template for the next.
So the unzipper
or the unwinder
is going to be helicase.
And as you can see,
this is unwinding.
So now when these come
back together, you
need gyrase because
it's going to introduce
negative super coils.
So in other words,
what that's going to
do is going to make
this coming back together
more relaxed. first
inhibitors of dna
gyrase like this one
is going to now and i
i don't know if many
of you have seen this
if you ever saw an
old telephone cord
what will happen is if
you don't unwind it it
becomes all curled up
and and if you ever
use one of those phones
i mean that was in
like my grandmother's
house, it would
become really hard to
answer the phone. So
basically, by inhibiting
DNA gyrase, you're
causing all these curled
up type of issues.
So what's going to
happen is that the
strands can't come back
together and you don't
get the replication.
Okay, so that's a
little bit about
that. There is
a cancer group,
etoposide, topecan,
that also works
on toporisomerase.
So So you'll see
that later in the
semester. But those
are used for
chemotherapy purposes.
Fluoroquinolones
will, in fact,
increase QT interval.
And that has to do
with the fact that they
block the potassium
channels in the heart.
They're going to
have an effect on
something called matrix
metalloproteinases.
When that's going to
be increased, what it
does is these enzymes
break down cartilage.
So the tendon rupture is
going to be
very important.
In pregnancy, these
are Category C. So
again, it's going
to affect the growth
of cartilage in the
developing baby.
And if you are a
pediatric patient, and
that's considered
to be under 18, they
don't really recommend
these unless there's
a risk versus
benefit because that
can affect growth
as well there is a
ciprootic which is a
topical eardrop that can
be used because you're
not going to get
much absorption but
if you have to be
treated for an
infection with an oral
medication and you're
in that population
you really have
to make sure that
there's no other
drug that you can use
drug interactions if
you have something that
inhibits cip 182 it
can raise the levels
of that drug and one
of them is theophylline
and theophylline is
a bronchodilator but
it causes cardiac
instability so that might
be an issue and then
just like tetracyclines
you have to space
them apart because if
you are taking say
calcium and you took a
fluoroquinolone or a
tetracycline there's a
chelation that occurs
and what that would mean
is that ultimately the
antibiotic does not
get absorbed and as you
can see the resistance
can be an alteration
of the dna gyrase
or a reduced uptake
of the antibiotic. So
that's more for gram
-negative in the porins.
So as I mentioned,
Cipro is more broad
spectrum. It can treat
positive like anthrax
and gram-negative like
Shigella, Salmonella.
And as you can see,
moxifloxacin and
levofloxacin, they
treat a lot more gram
-positive and S-pneumonia
is one of them.
so now we will do
viral meningitis
and I will say
with viruses
unless there's a
specific virus most of it
is going to be
supportive treatment okay
and the other thing is
and you know we'll go
back to this point if
it's something like
measles, mumps,
and influenza,
vaccinate.
So viral meningitis,
the enteroviruses, is
included in 85% of
all viral meningitis.
And this includes
poliovirus,
kakasaki, A and B,
and echoviruses. And
usually these are
transmitted either through
respiratory route or
through oral *****. so
again the idea of
hygiene is going to be
very important okay
management is supportive
so be mindful of
dehydration if they have
fever give them acetaminophen
make sure they're
getting rest the
concern is mostly going
to be for the elderly
and immunosuppressed
because elderly are going
to be very sensitive
to the effects of
dehydration so this
might necessitate
depending on where you are
and how quickly
supportive therapy is
started it may necessitate
a hospitalization so
again being aware what
you can do at home
and what you need to
present to the hospital
when you have to
Arbovirus is 5% of
meningitis cases And I
think for this part of
the country Probably
in the last 15 years
They talk about the
West Nile virus every
summer But Zika is
also included And
this comes from a bite
So what you would do
is prevent by using
an insect repellent
And this is definitely
true If we're
talking about any of
these viruses, if
you're going hiking in
the woods and you're
worrying about deer
tick or Lyme disease,
it makes sense.
The issue with
this is that
patients can end up
getting encephalitis
or they can get seizures.
So the treatment is
supportive. Make sure
that you're monitoring
if they're getting
a seizure. If they
have a seizure, you
usually would give
like a benzodiazepine.
And then to prevent
some of that brain
swelling, you would
use a glucocorticoid.
So again, we've been
through this once,
maybe twice, and we'll
be through it again
by the end of the
semester. And next is
glucocorticoids. So we
can't say it enough.
This group is going to
start at the
starting point
of producing
prostaglandins and
leukotrienes. It's
going to bind right here
at phospholipase
A2. so that's going
to prevent
arachnidonic acid from
being formed and
then that's going to
prevent prostaglandins
and leukotrienes
so for this it would
be mainly here working
against producing
prostaglandins for
respiratory again it
would be leukotrienes
and we have other
drugs we have ziluton
and the leukotriene
receptor antagonist
which I'll talk about
when we do allergies.
And then over
here, when we're
talking about
cyclooxygenase, we
have NSAIDs, we
have celecoxib.
And then, of
course, so that we
never, ever forget,
thromboxane is
going to be aspirin,
low-dose aspirin
for cardiovascular
protection.
And then glucocorticoids
are nuclear receptor.
The drug comes in,
the receptor is
maintained stable with
heat shock proteins,
the drug binds, heat
shock proteins go,
they bind together,
they dimerize, it
continues in the
nucleus, you increase
transcription, and you
get induction of messenger
RNA, protein formation,
and response.
you taper slowly
because you can get HPA
suppression so if
you're going from oral
to inhaled make
sure you taper that
if you're going
from a 50 milligram
dose to a 10 milligram
dose you don't
do it in one day
and then the adverse
effects metabolic
you're increasing
gluconeogenesis you're
increasing free fatty
acids so you may be
increasing sugar you
may be increasing
lipids in your patient.
In the bone, you're
increasing osteoclasts.
You're excreting
vitamin D faster than
you're absorbing the
calcium, so that affects
bone. You're going
to decrease growth.
You may affect
mood, given the fact
that it can lower
TSH and it can
change some of the
neurotransmitters in the
brain. Patients can
become more depressed or
even psychotic and
then with the blood
pressure in in the kidney
it allows more sodium
and water to be taken
up and that's going
to raise blood pressure
so these are not to
be used more than two
weeks they're used for
acute management for
something like this you
probably would need
just a few doses okay
you would not give it
to them they would not
go home with it is
what i'm trying to say.
So again, now we go
into viral meningitis
and, you know, mumps
is a leading cause
of meningitis in
underdeveloped countries.
Here,
again, it should
be low. We hope so
because we have
the vaccinations.
So again, when it comes
to influenza, mumps,
and measles that
can lead to viral
meningitis, we can't
stay enough to vaccinate.
For influenza, we
have two drugs,
zanamivir, which
is inhaled,
and acyltamivir,
which is oral.
They both work
at an enzyme
known as neuraminidase.
Now, when the virus
is formed, it stays
next to this cell, the
host cell, with
a receptor.
And that receptor is
made of sialic acid.
Neuraminidase comes
in and breaks,
separates them. It
causes a cleavage.
So now the virus
leaves the host and it
could go on and
affect other cells.
and that's how the
virus activates, it
spreads, such and such.
So a neuraminidase
inhibitor like
acyltamivir or Tamiflu,
which you
probably heard it
being used for a
lot of the H1N1,
would come here now
and prevent that from
happening. So if the
virus stays close to
the host, eventually
it's going to die.
So that's neuraminidase
inhibitors.
So,
****** is
involved in 4% of
the cases of
viral meningitis.
****** simplex virus
2 is the most common.
And we also have
varicella and
cytomegalovirus. CMV,
I'm going to say the
mnemonic is owl's
eyes, I believe.
Normally, acyclovir
will be beneficial.
But if those patients
that have maybe
severe CMV or they
have HIV, you have
to use something
stronger, Ganciclovir.
And in this star here,
this heart therapy,
I want to say that
for that, I will
mention that HIV
patients should be on
heart therapy. So
what I'm trying to say
is, should they get
these viruses, you
may have to make
sure that they are
very compliant with
their heart therapy.
Okay, because
that is where
it's going to
be critical.
Because they're going
to be immunosuppressed
with these infections.
So you want
to make sure they're
on heart therapy.
So aciclovir, pensiclovir,
and ganciclovir.
What will happen
is, you're going
to get participation
of enzymes.
And the enzyme I'm
talking about is
thymidine kinase.
And that's going
to transfer or
convert this group
of medications into
a monophosphate.
Now, host kinases,
the ones that
are in our
body, will make
this ultimately
a triphosphate.
The triphosphate is
what is going to exert
the drug action.
That's where it's going
to incorporate
itself into the viral
DNA chain and stop
the chain from getting
longer. And it's
also going to inhibit
the viral DNA polymerase
and that's going
to stop the synthesis
of the viral DNA.
So keep this in mind. You
need two
phosphorylations.
One of them
is going to be
dependent on
thymidine kinase.
there are certain
times where this could
be mutated. So what
do you think will
happen? If this
enzyme is mutated,
well, that means it's
not going to become
a monophosphate.
And you're going
to end up getting
resistance because you
can't make what you
ultimately need.
So the idea here is
in this case where the
patient has this
resistance, you have to
give something that is
already fluorinated.
So we have trifluoridine,
so fluorinated
Cidolfovir, which
is fluorinated And
Foscoronet, which is
also fluorinated So
these would be the
ones for the resistance
Aciclovir can
be used by IV or
topical route For
IV, that's when
you have more
serious infections
and the IV is
going to cause
more of the
adverse effects.
So the issue is
going to be something
that can happen
is that aciclovir
can precipitate
in the tubules
and that can cause
an obstruction.
So the way we manage that
is by giving hydration.
Because the
metabolite there, the
crystallization, can
lead to the patient
with this
obstruction, they can
have an increased
risk of seizures.
Valsiclovir is
valvenated. So it's a
pro-drug. So you
don't have to give
valsiclovir as many
times as you would with
aciclovir. So when
somebody say had,
I don't know, chicken
pox, and they took
aciclovir, they
would have to take
aciclovir like four
or five times a day.
With valciclovir, they
would be okay with
taking it twice or
sometimes even once a day.
So the valinated
component makes
the pharmacokinetics
a little bit
better with
respect to dosing.
And then as I said,
foscarinate is
phosphorylated. So you
don't have to worry about
the mutation in the
thymidine kinase.
hypocalcemia can
occur with foscar
net that might
be due to the
fact that the
drug will complex
calcium and chelated
and allow it to
be excreted or it
could be that this
drug decreases
magnesium it allows
it to be excreted
and lowering
magnesium will also
lead to hypocalcemia
and that has an effect
on parathyroid hormone.
So remember,
hypocalcemia could be an
issue. Patients can
get neurological
issues, cramps,
tingling, seizures.
Ganciclovir is a
guanosine analog.
It has a poor
bioavailability.
You can give it IV
or use the valve
ganciclovir. Same principle.
Adding a valine is
going to make this
able to be given less
if you're enhancing
the bioavailability.
The use is CMV
or owl's eyes.
It's a thousand
times more
effective than a
ciclovir for CMV.
So this is the
drug for CMV.
the adverse effects
has to do with the fact
that it can inhibit
the synthesis of DNA and
lymphocytes so
that's where you get
the bone marrow
suppression
resistance there
can be a mutation in
the DNA polymerase
or the lack of
thymidine kinase so
in that case again you
would go with something
like Foskarnet
so with fungal meningitis
it's going to be
caused by cryptococcus
this is very serious
again it's going to
be more prevalent in
those patients that
have immunosuppression
like HIV patients
you want to give
three medications
they have three different
mechanisms of action
number one and they have
different toxicities
And that's something
that's important
because sometimes three
drugs, it's not just
for the mechanism, but
it's just to keep the
toxicity of the other
drugs kind of level.
So this is an
important slide where
it's almost like
my favorite slide
because it has
almost all of the
antifungal mechanisms
in the picture.
So number one,
Amphotericin, as you can
see, you see the cell
membrane and Nystatin.
these drugs
bind to the cell
membrane and
they cause pores
in the ergosterol
because our membranes
are made with
cholesterol the fungal
cell uses ergosterol
when it makes these
pores, everything
leaks out sodium,
water, potassium and
the cell wall dies
nystatin we're not
going to see here but
nystatin you'll talk
about When we talk about
patients that maybe
didn't use a rinse after
inhaling an inhaled
corticoid, they get
candidiasis of the mouth,
so we might give them
some of that in the
pharmacy to kind of
swish and spit or swish
and swallow, depending
on how far the fungal
infection has gone.
When we're talking
about creating almost
like a cross-linking,
like we would see
with beta-lactams,
we have beta-glucan.
And that is going
to be inhibited
by echinocandins,
like casperfungin.
It's not going to be the
drugs we'll
talk about here.
Microtubules we
won't talk about,
but microtubules
are going
to be affected
by griziofolvin.
they're going
to affect the
action in the
mitotic spindle
squalene as you can
see here to squalene
epoxide is going
to be blocked by
terbinifine because
ultimately these two steps
with squalene and
linosterol are going
to make your ergosterol
we're not going
to talk about
terbinifine because
terbinifine you'll see
it If you've ever gone
to the pharmacy and
you had maybe an
athlete's foot and
you picked up Lamisil.
And then squalene
to linosterol,
again,
would be made.
But then linosterol
to ergosterol, there's
an enzyme called 14
-alpha-d-methylase.
That step is going
to be blocked with
something like
itraconazole, ketoconazole.
And then when
we're talking
about the fungal
cell and the
creation of DNA
proteins and RNA,
you do have a
medication that
will block that
from happening,
block replication
of DNA and
RNA, and that's
flucytosine.
And it makes a
metabolite known
as 5-fluorouracil
or 5-FU.
And you'll see this
again when you do cancer.
This drug that's
used for the fungal
cell and the one
used for cancer,
they're going to
affect pyrimidines.
So one of the effects
of this one and
the cancer drug is
going to be DNA,
bone marrow depression,
and bone marrow
suppression, and that's
due to that fact.
Okay, so that's
just a little
bit about this picture.
So amphotericin
is broad spectrum.
it can be given
intrathecally or
intraventricular so it
can be injected into the
spinal cord and into
the ventricles of the
brain and due to the
mechanism by making
fenestirations it's
going to stop ergosterol
from surviving
because you're getting
rid of the ions in
the fluid the adverse
effects here. Again,
I'm going to go back
to first aid. This
is AMFO the terrible.
When this gets
infused, almost always
patients are
going to feel hot
and cold. We call
it shake and bake.
You can prevent
that by giving
them maybe some
acetaminophen.
The other thing is
that since Since this
drug is binding to
membranes, it's going
to bind to the
kidney cell membrane.
And that will now do
a couple of things.
It will leak out
contents from the kidney.
It will also
cause a degree of
vasoconstriction. And
if that's happening and
you're reducing blood
flow, you're also
reducing glomerular
filtration rate. So this
is one of the most
toxic renal drugs.
The other thing
is that a few
years ago, I got
a student that
showed me a first
aid question,
or actually a
USMLE question.
And the patient presented
with a ventricular
arrhythmia.
after getting some
medication a while back.
And looking at
it, the correct
answer was amphotericin.
So the student said,
I don't remember
amphotericin being a drug
that was cardiotoxic.
It's a drug that's
nephrotoxic. And I said,
did you remember the
mechanism? And they
ended up saying, yeah,
it allows a leakage of
ions. yeah so that's
sodium calcium and
potassium that's part
of the action potential
so it was a very
interesting question because
i didn't expect it
either i thought it was
going to be nephrotoxicity
as well but then
they they came in and
they they snuck in
the heart thing it
makes sense because if
you're losing these ions
then you do put yourself
at trouble for action
potential changes
how do you manage the
renal toxicity just
like you you saw
with aciclovir make
sure the patient is
is well hydrated the
other thing you can
do is put this in a
liposome a liposome
means that the drug
goes to the place
where it needs to treat
so amphosome it
will go to the cells
that are fungal,
and it would
try to spare
them renal cells.
Doxorubicin, which
we talked about
earlier, and you'll
talk about it again,
there is a liposome
for that too,
where doxorubicin, that
liposome goes to the
cancer cell and it
tries to spare the heart
because doxorubicin
is toxic to the heart.
fluconazole is the
azole that we use
because this one
gets into the CSF
voroconazole is used
for systemic infections
itraconazole is used
mainly for nail ******
all of them inhibit
14-alpha-D-methylase
so the step from
linosterol to ergosterol
The adverse
effects, these
drugs are an
inhibitor of SIP.
They also can create
toxic metabolites
that affect the
liver, and that
might raise liver
function tests.
And then ketoconazole,
which you
could buy with
over-the-counter
for your dandruff,
finiserol,
that has an anti
-androgen effect
and that can lead
to gynecomastia.
And then flucidocine
is the last
one. This is
converted to 5
-fluorouracil. It's
a pyrimidine analog.
And by doing that,
it's blocking
DNA and RNA and
even proteins.
it's used with
amphotericin to stop number
one the resistance
because you have three
mechanisms on board
and also to reduce
some of the toxicities
so you don't need
a big dose of amphotericin
to create renal
injury but the adverse
effects since it
affects DNA synthesis
specifically pyrimidine
you may get bone
marrow suppression
so summary again and
i highlighted those
that are less than
50 or those that are
greater than 50 and
immunosuppressed it's
got to be the third
generation vanco for
covering MRSA and
ampicillin for the
immunosuppressed because
you might be worried
about some listeria
infection because
immunosuppressed and
elderly are going to be
more sensitive to a
listeria infection than
those that are younger
and not immunosuppressed.
I think with listeria
also, we would
be worried with
pregnant patients.
As you can see
with the pediatric
patient, you want
to do something
like a cell wall
inhibitor, beta-lactam.
So again,
ceftriaxone is there.
Meningitis with a
penicillin allergy
consider moxifloxacin
the fluoroquinolone
and vanco again to
cover you against MRSA
so that's it for today
I will have a question
review which I believe
will be helpful
because you know
antibiotics are very big
when it comes to
pharmacology no matter what
type of physician that
you elect to be you're
going to need to know
about antibiotics
consistently so thank
you for your attention
and I will see you
soon have a great day